nfl draft reaction the quarterbacks of
the future that the various teams have
quarterbacks of the president what have
they done to help them
have a more fruitful future and for joe
burrow the number one overall pick in
2020 job number one
is protect him keep him from getting
injured
keep him from having to rehab another
torn acl and
hey i remember when carson palmer had
his torn acl took him a year
to get to the point where he could plant
that left leg comfortably
he was seeing ghosts you know you you
are you're gonna you know there's a lot
of issues there
and instead of protecting him with penne
sewell they go jamar chase i know
we said hey you can either get rid of
the ball faster because the guy's open
or you can hold it a little longer
because you're getting better blocking
they had to have at some level agonized
over whether they were doing the right
thing there chris
i think so uh you know i mean i think it
was a quietly uh
a big topic of conversation just around
the league in general to know what they
would do there because it
it wasn't an easy choice i think that
there's you know you you could talk to
some people in the league and go
they're gonna go man it's awesome we
think jamar chase was special
that's great and you could talk to other
people in the league that i've
that i've had conversation with that go
man penny sewell might be a
hall of fame left tackle you just don't
pass that up and those type of things so
this is one of those things that you
know like uh trey lands and mac jones
and justin fields how they're all going
to be compared going forward
jamar chases you know stats and
everything like that he's going to be
compared to penne sewell to a degree
there's no doubt but either way like
what we talked about in the lead up to
the draft
is exactly what what happened with
cincinnati we knew
there'd be some good offensive linemen
there to be had at the top of the second
round
and some really talented ones and the
guy they got in the second round
jackson carmen he has
he's a big time player i mean he really
is he has the potential
to really be i think every bit as good
as penne sewell
talking about a giant human being a
great athlete
great power i think some of the mistakes
you saw on film from him
were more of the scheme that they do in
clemson and what they asked him to do
i don't think it was realistic always so
they rolled the dice
and went that way on a kid that is grew
up
i think not far from the cincinnati
bango's uh practice facility they have
great knowledge of the guy all together
and i think right away he slips in a
guard but ultimately mike
i think he's gonna end up being the left
tackle and they're gonna knock in
um what the hell is the alabama's guide
that they drafted in the first round
the tackle uh jonah i'm blanking on his
name
a few years ago no
the first round alabama lineman they
took two years ago
that got hurt you're not going to help
me out your cat you can't remember
either it's gonna kill me i can't
remember either i'm just gonna sit here
and keep my mouth shut that's what the
producer's for
the producer doesn't know either um
regardless
he's got jonah hill on his head too
jonah williams close enough jonah
williams
what would you do what would you have
done there would you have gone with the
quarterback or would you have gone with
the penney sewell
well i wouldn't have gone with the
quarterback i mean there's a sewer yeah
but but you know what if you have a guy
who can
especially for this year help the
interior of the offensive line
because if you are going to have a guy
who's concerned about planting the left
leg
you could argue it's more important to
protect him up the middle
than it is to protect him around the
edge because if you're going to see
ghosts you're not going to see the
ghosts around the edge you need to have
the protection right
stepping into it like you said right and
that that's that gets
underrated but but what's the way to get
to tom brady
it's not come around the edge he's going
to jump up in the pocket he does that
madden glitch move
that he does like no one else right when
the walls are caving in he scoots up
and throws the ball you come up the
middle like that
guard guard center and you you collapse
it that way
you got nowhere to go yeah so if you got
a guy who's going to be worried about
planting his left leg
maybe they're operating next level in
cincinnati now get the receiver
who's going to be dominant and who knows
the guy and then you get a great guard
and and maybe you just need him to play
guard for one year so
joe burrow gets his confidence back in
that left leg there there may be
there may be some genius unfolding in
the queen city of ohio
yeah it was hopefully we know that
they need to protect joe that was an
issue last year
he's got to protect himself they got to
open up some holes
you know for further joe mixon at
running back and they drafted some lymon
later on in the draft too that
i'm sure they're they're hoping can
contribute at least give them depth at
the
at the positions there and everything
like that uh
so overall they definitely helped out
joe burrow
there's no doubt about that but that's
going to be the big question
is should they have should they have
gone penny sewell and taken a top
receiver
you know in the top of the second round
and to me
i think there was a greater gap between
the top receiver and who you could get
at the top of the second round as
compared to
the tackle and the lineman you could get
at the second round
and maybe i'm in the minority there
because i'm a jackson carmen fan and i
think he's special but
uh i think i probably would have erred
on doing what the bengals did too
well and it helped that burrow and chase
have that connection right especially
since
chase sat out all of the 2020 season
he's one of the guys who chose to opt
out and even though we fully support
that it does
create a practical dilemma when you're
trying to project what a guy's going to
do after not playing
for a full year but chase clearly good
enough to overcome that and having that
burrow relationship
didn't hurt i still wonder if they
could have traded down and still got
chase it all comes down to whether or
not the dolphins would have taken
uh jaylen waddle over chase i i was
under the impression that they were
going to take waddle over chase if both
were on the board but the bengals
very conservative small c conservative
when it comes to this kind of stuff
they didn't want to take that chance
they wanted the guy that they wanted and
they got him
and i i i think they are moving in the
right direction it's not going to be
easy
toughest division in football arguably
right now but uh
you know they're doing what they have to
do to put the weapons around
burrow and the help in place so he can
stay healthy once he gets healthy but
this kid look at that lineup
all right weapons it's pretty damn good
they they could be
very very good offensively and they may
need to be very very good offensively
with the browns and the ravens and the
steelers in the division yeah no
definitely i mean i
you know their defense they've done some
good things in free agency there and
everything like that but i do think it's
gonna
be about them having to ride this
offense certainly i don't think the
defense is gonna look at it and go oh
this will be a top 10 unit in football
or anything like that the big thing
though i mean that's
that's a special unit of skill guys and
if their offensive line
can play at you know an above average
level or towards the top half of the
league or anything like that
they will be tough to match up with all
those guys and that'll make them you
know a little bit of a scoring machine
and we saw burrow
when he kind of got in a groove there
after the first few weeks of the season
last year
i mean he started picking people apart
and making plays and
they beat some teams they shouldn't have
beat and everything like that so
i'm i'm really rooting for joe burrow i
hope he gets back
close to 100 for the start of the year
and uh let's see what this bengals team
can do because it is a tough division
like you said quarterback taken five
spots after borough last year who became
the offensive rookie of the year
after he was thrust into service due to
tyrod taylor's misadventures with dr
needle
justin herbert did he get enough help
from
the los angeles chargers to help him go
next level i know they really want to
pen a sewell but they got lucky rashaan
slater fell to them at 13. yeah
that has to be a huge bonus for a team
that
wants to avoid justin herbert getting
himself injured
yeah no doubt i mean i think that was
the number one
issue with their football team that had
to be addressed
i mean there was no doubt about it you
know the chargers offensively
got a lot of things to like i mean we
know we know that
receiving core is pretty damn good and
special that way
but it is about like yeah can they get a
run game and be consistent there and of
course
protect justin herbert they've been
working on this offensive line for the
last two years slater's awesome
kind of a can't miss prospect that way
you know and the fact too of like
okay we we think he can play tackle but
i don't think there's any doubt
he can play guard and do all of that
stuff too so there's a little
flexibility with the football player too
here
to just make sure you get the top five
offensive alignment on the field
together here in this year
but from that you know again i think
that was the essential
big time most glaring need for the
football team and you're right they're
fortunate that
a guy like slater was still on the board
there at pick 13. a lot of people viewed
him as a top 10 pick
it is amazing to me how the chargers
just can't register on the national
radar screen right
they are the the junior team in la
they're the
tenants in the stadium that's owned by
the rams but
i think and it's not going to help that
you know the chiefs are as good as they
are
and it definitely won't help if aaron
rodgers ends up on the pro
seriously but but the chargers i think
are
they're you know the key is keeping
their key players healthy
and if they can do that they can be a
factor they were just
12 and 4 not that long ago and you can
make the argument that justin herbert is
an upgrade over phillip rivers all due
respect to philip rivers but
but what we've seen from herbert so far
has been great
and the the chargers could be one of
those teams where like the bills last
year when it happens
we'll say you know we should have seen
that coming yeah i agreed
i think they're definitely like one of
those teams that you put in that
category with like the miami dolphins
right even too
uh you know i'll even say the carolina
panthers this year
like just got a little star next to them
to go of those teams that didn't make
the playoffs
that this could be one of those teams i
mean we talked about it a lot last year
that's what didn't make sense about
their football team
i mean there was a point last year where
they had a top 10 offense and a top 10
defense
in the league in the nfl both sides of
the ball but it wasn't translating to
wins
so that tells you the roster there's a
lot of good there defense really has got
like
zero needs at any level they're special
there
offense i mean we talked you know we
just hit it herbert
with those receivers they got i mean
he's got two a great duo and williams
and keenan allen some of those younger
guys
they drafted a kid from tennessee and
josh palmer who's a good all-around can
do
everything receiver they drafted a tight
end and mckitty from georgia
who's more of a long pass catching tight
end mike maybe
alessa gaseki down in miami just to
paint a picture
of the body right like that longer type
tight end that kind of guy
so yeah they address their needs and the
chargers i'm with you mike i think
they're one of those teams where you
just go
watch out they could be in the mix of
things and herbert by all accounts looks
like he's going
to be a superstar you mentioned the
dolphins is a team that you put a star
next to as a potential playoff team they
got close last year
did they do enough to help out tuatanga
viloa and that's a weird question to ask
because it implies that they really want
to help out tuatanga valloa
there's still a sense of ambivalence
that emanates from the fact that he was
benched on multiple occasions last year
for ryan fitzpatrick
and now they have jacoby brisette as the
guy who could be the quote-unquote
relief pitcher
as brian flores used that term at one
point last year
but do they have enough around to it to
help to become the best version of him
of himself that he can be chris i think
so i do
you know one they they addressed their
number one issue right off the bat
and that was like they needed that one
who's gonna be
who's the guy that we can give a reverse
to or throw a short pass to on our
football team
that can do something and make a big
play and like
take the pressure off the offense a
little bit not always have to be about
we got to run the ball we got to execute
the offensive coordinators got to call
the exact perfect play all the time
jalen waddle is going to give them you
know some wiggle room there he's a
playmaker
and to go along with the two big
receivers they got on the outside and
gaseki holy crapola batman
you know and the biggest thing is
the biggest thing too is just like yes
you get a hunter long in the third round
who you could argue is the best blocking
tight end in the whole draft
and has a little pass game value so
that's going to help out too
in the offense liam eichenberg is nfl
ready to start right now
and the big thing is where i would just
go that's going to be big with tua
yeah we got jalen weil and hunter long
and leon mikenberg
but the offensive line has got a first
rounder on it
from last year and a second rounder on
it from last year
they're stacked up front they are like
putting on a clinic
on team building with the miami dolphins
they're you're gonna we're coming away
with every position going
damn is that one of the top units in
football at that position
damn is that one of the top unit i mean
it's really getting scary what they're
doing so
uh yes they helped tua out while also
helping out
their whole football team with two
amazing defensive picks in the first and
second round too so i mean
i love what the dolphins are doing i'm a
huge fan of greer and flores and what
they're what they're building down there
afc east potential holy crap right
extremely
competitive if zach wilson delivers on
his promise with the jets
the patriots going all in to get better
with their free agency spending and now
they have a quarterback to develop in
mac jones
the dolphins if tua becomes the guy that
they thought he was when they made him
the fifth overall pick and with all this
great help around him and the great
coaching
and then the bills the bills are the
bills and
it's unreal you know it may be hard
remember how easy it was for the
patriots
to pencil themselves in for the afc
championship every year because they ran
roughshod over the rest of the division
now it's going to be
you know you got to scratch and claw and
you may not get that by
you may never have a team coming out of
that division getting the bye because
they're going to be dragged down
by the other teams as they as they
scratch and claw each other to get to
the top
so yeah good news bad news very
competitive division but uh good luck
laying the foundation to get to the
super bowl we're in a division that is
that competitive
what about the jaguars as we flip it to
a non-competitive division
yeah trevor lawrence is clearly the guy
unquestioned
did they do enough and do they have
enough to allow him
to to get to his ceiling whatever it may
be sooner rather than later i i i
believe so i mean again
like miami i think if you ask me like
the three teams that
won the draft all right that that's
where i'm gonna go
the jaguars the dolphins the jets would
be the teams that i would throw out
there
right off the bat i mean the jaguars
first off just like
they had a year of i mean a draft of
like it was like they were
in my in my in my uh house for my draft
evaluations i love their draft
i mean yes trevor lawrence awesome my
second quarterback
atn was my first running back tyson
campbell
was my second corner walker little mike
this is a guy nobody knows of because he
opted out last year
and the year before that he tore his acl
this is a
like talent-wise the man he is
is a top 10 offensive lineman talent
they got in the second round he's a top
10 pick
if things are normal so that's
phenomenal
got a safety who might be the most
physically gifted safety in the whole
draft but tore his acl last year
and andre cisco from syracuse and then
even jay tufelli from usc is a hell of a
good player but yes i think they've done
enough
to help out um
trevor lawrence definitely atn was a
great pick there's no doubt
you know just he's gonna serve a lot of
roles as far as what he can do for that
offense
they gotta they got some weapons and
free agency on the offensive side of the
ball too
you know uh i mean and even in last
year's draft but to get marvin jones
they have levishka channel dj shark is
one of the better receivers in football
that nobody knows about
so i do think there's enough there and
they're building something that i like
in clemson at least uh
the way it looks right now what about
you you mentioned a couple of guys who
were drafted by the jaguars around two
and three despite having torn acls i'm
stunned that former 49ers gm trent bauke
would sign and draft guys who have torn
acls wasn't that his thing
like every year they were taking a
chance on a guy with a torn acl when he
was the gm there well yeah i don't
remember
i don't remember a whole lot of them
working out headlights
running back at that south carolina
right right
and that was others too yeah there was a
florida state there was a florida state
defensive lineman
who fell out of round one who would have
been around one prospect uh
but but that was kind of their thing it
was they were never deterred by torn
acls and trent bauke he's still not just
and look it's not the injury it used to
no it's not that's right but
some guys uh they never quite get back
to being who they were but i
look i just with the jaguars and with
this urban meyer experiment
i understand what they're doing from a
business standpoint
they're trying to make the team
attractive they're trying to sell
tickets
and it's working it's a new day it's a
new page it's a new approach
will it work or not i just want to wait
and see because every time
we have one of these new approach
coaches
you know greg schiano chip kelly these
college guys are going to bring in all
these new and different ways i just
i i'm just skeptical i choose to be
skeptical
because when was the last time a college
coach took the nfl by storm it was jimmy
johnson 30 years ago and maybe urban
meyer
maybe it's due maybe it's time maybe
urban meyer is going to come in
and it's going to be ohio state south
and they're going to be great right out
of the gates
but uh you know i i you count people
carol is like a
nfl coach you went to college yeah and
came back like was out yeah okay i just
wanted to clarify that
yeah i mean now now he was better after
his experience at usc
right than he ever was before that but
you could argue he never really got a
full and fair chance with the jets or
the patriots sure but
um i i i'm just i'm just skeptical
because
look where where were the other suitors
for urban meyer
it's not like there was a land rush for
urban meyer there there was one mention
as he was closing in on a deal with the
jaguars that the chargers
had interest and i think that was just
posturing to get him whatever he got and
we still haven't heard what he got i
remember hearing he wanted 12 million
and there was like pushback oh no that's
not a relevant number well
there's got to be a rel were they paying
him in bitcoin there's got to be a
relevant number somewhere
as to what the guy's getting paid uh i i
just think that
that well i'll believe it when i see it
i just i i'm too familiar
with what happened with chip kelly what
happened with greg schiano when we get
this hello oh here comes this college
coach it's going to change everything
let's see and maybe they've got enough
great players and it won't matter we'll
see what they can do
but they were 1 in 15 last year so they
got a lot of work to do to get back to
the team that they almost were in 2017
when they nearly got to the super bowl
all right zach wilson in the jets
speaking of another team that i'll
believe it when i see it
you love zach wilson he was your number
one quarterback do the jets
have enough and have they done enough to
get the help around zach wilson to make
him what he needs to be i think so i
mean i think that it's an organization
that at least like
i think at a base level you could see
they learn from past
mistakes or at least are aware of like
how
sam darnold was set up or not set up for
any success with the new york jets when
he got drafted at number three
so yes again you heard me say already i
think the jets are one of the team that
one
you know one of the teams that won the
draft okay wait wait we got a good
quarterback what are we gonna do all
right
and we got a system where we like
athletic lineman and do those things
alright so now we got the quarterback
that does that
all right what are we gonna do on the
offensive line they get a guy that's
i think they look at it go we think he's
one of the better guards in the nfl
right off the bat they could throw him
in right there
and i think he could play right tackle
too but then again i get elijah moore
to go with corey davis and let's not
forget they drafted denzel
mims last year and all of that you know
so now you got a guy again
a little bit like jalen waddle in miami
a guy that can work the middle of the
field be a weapon do those things in
elijah moore
great pick there and then i think one of
the steals of the draft the fact that
they got michael carter
in the fourth round i mean they had a
run to the podium at that point
he's the perfect fit for that offense
he's
he's devonte freeman we saw what devonte
freeman did with shanahan down in
atlanta
you know this is a guy that can break
ankles make people miss he's a little
bit of a smaller running back at like
200 pounds
but man he can fly and he's got great
change of direction ability and all
those type of things so
uh yes i think they did the right thing
to help support their young quarterback
and they're building a a really i think
an impressive roster there over the last
two years with the new york jets
bottom line is though at the end of the
day
there's 32 teams and for every good team
there must be a bad team
so you know some of these teams and
we're
we're still in the afterglow of the
selling of hope that comes from the
draft and
every team has unlimited possibilities
going in to 2021 and
at some point they got to play the games
and people will stop being zero and zero
and there will be teams that dip
well below 500. hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports